♪ ♪
>> Brian: HI, EVERYBODY,
WELCOME BACK.
A TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE FACING AN
ONSLAUGHT OF SHAMING, SNAPPING
ADD TO DEBRA MESSING FOR SAYING
THAT HIS DONORS SHOULD BE OUTED.
AND NOW WE HAVE ANOTHER
OUTRAGEOUS EXAMPLE.
YOU HAVE A DELIBERATE AUTHOR
TAKING TO TWITTER TO TELL PEOPLE
TO AVOID WEARING A RED HAT.
"IS ANYBODY ELSE UNCOMFORTABLE
THESE DAYS BY ANYONE WEARING ANY
TYPE OF RED BASEBALL CAP, LIKE
THE ST. LOUIS CARDINALS, MAYBE
THEY DON'T WEAR RED CAPS
ANYMORE, NORMAL PEOPLE.
ALSO FOR THE LOVE OF GOD, THE
CLEVER FOLKS WEARING MAKE
AMERICA READ AGAIN, OR WHATEVER,
YOU'RE MAKING EVERYBODY SCARED.
DON'T DO IT."
BANNING RED CAPS, IS THIS AN
IDEA OF WHOSE TIME HAS COME.
>> Jesse: THEY CANNOT HANDLE A
HAT, THEY GET UPSET WHEN YOU EAT
A HAMBURGER.
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO DRIVE
SOMEWHERE.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
HOUSE IS PROPERLY INSULATED.
STAY OUT OF MY HOUSE IN MY
KITCHEN AND MY CLOSET.
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE ALWAYS SAYING
STAY OUT OF MY BEDROOM, WELL,
GET OUT OF MY CLOSET.
I CANNOT WEAR MY PHILLIES CAP
BECAUSE IT WILL TRIGGER SOME
LIBERAL.
>> Brian: IS THIS TRULY
OVER-THE-TOP?
BRINGING PEOPLE BACK DOWN TO
EARTH AND MAKING PEOPLE REALIZE
WE ARE OVERREACTING.
>> Dagen: THEY ARE ANGRY ABOUT
RED HATS, SO MY EXTENSION THEY
HATE SANTA CLAUS.
AND YOU KNOW, I WOULD NOT WANT
TO MAKE ANYBODY FROM
PHILADELPHIA WHERE --
>> Jesse: WE ARE ALREADY
MAKING NEW SCARED.
>> Dagen: WHO MAKES ME MORE
FRIGHTENED, RED SOX FANS.
DO NOT BRING ON THE WRATH OF A
RED SOX FAN.
>> Brian: THIS IS WHAT THEY
PUT OUT.
ARE YOU TRIGGERED WHEN YOU SEE A
RED CAP?
>> Juan: I AM A BIG WASHINGTON
NATIONALS FAN, SO WE WEAR RED
HATS.
IN FACT, EVEN THE CAPITALS HAVE
A THING ABOUT GET YOUR RED ON IN
WASHINGTON.
SO THIS IS KIND OF NUTS.
DO I UNDERSTAND WHAT SHE IS
SAYING?
YES, I DO, BECAUSE THERE ARE
LOTS OF PEOPLE WHO LIKE TO TROLL
LIBERALS, AND I THINK THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO DON'T EVEN PERCEIVE
THAT THAT HAD TO, THEM MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN HAT, WHAT IT
SAYS TO PEOPLE OF COLOR.
WHAT IT SAYS TO IMMIGRANTS AND A
LOT OF WOMEN IN THIS COUNTRY, IT
IS THREATENING.
>> Jesse: WAIT A MINUTE, HOW
IS THAT THREATENING?
IT IS A HAT.
SPIN ON THE KIND OF POLICIES AND
THINGS THAT WE HAVE SEEN TAKE
PLACE IN THE COUNTRY, FROM
CHARLOTTESVILLE --
>> Jesse: WE ARE MAKE AN
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
>> Juan: OH, YEAH.
IT'S NOT THE POLITICS, IT'S THAT
YOU ARE INTENTIONALLY SENDING A
VERY DIVISIVE MESSAGE.
BUT I THINK THAT TRUMP PEOPLE DO
NOT EVEN PERCEIVE IT.
>> Brian: PEOPLE DO NOT
PERCEIVE IT THE WAY THAT JUAN
PERCEIVES IT.
>> Emily: CLEARLY THAT ONE
WOMAN DOES.
TO ME I AM LIKE, KEEP IT UP,
KEEP IT UP, BECAUSE ALL THIS IS
GOING TO DO IS GALVANIZE
EVERYONE ELSE, BECAUSE IT IS NOW
GOING INTO THE NORMAL FANDOM OF
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
AND THE HYPOCRISY OF HOLLYWOOD,
WHERE EVERYONE AND ALL OF THE
ACTORS HAVE IN THEIR TWITTER
BIOS I AM AN ACTIVIST, AND DEBRA
MESSING TWEETED OUT A BLACK VOTE
FOR TRUMP IS MENTAL ILLNESS.
SHE LATER APOLOGIZED, BUT IF I
WERE TO SAY THAT, IF SOMETHING
WAS TO SAY THAT, --
>> Jesse: THEY CALLED
KANYE WEST MENTALLY ILL.
>> Emily: AND SOMEHOW THEY ARE
SELF LABELING ACTIVISTS.
>> Brian: HAS IT OCCURRED TO
YOU THAT IT SAYS KEEP AMERICA
GREAT, THAT HE IS TALKING ABOUT
THE EIGHT YEARS OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND THE APOLOGY
TOUR, AND THE ACQUIESCENCE ON
THE WORLD STAGE AND THE
PROTECTION OF THE AMERICAN DREAM
AND PRIDE, NOT BACK TO SLAVERY
IN PRECIVIL WAR TALK?
>> Juan: I THINK IT IS BACK TO
1950, WOMEN IN THEIR PLACE.
>> Brian: HE HAS NEVER SAID
THAT.
>> Juan: THAT IS WHAT IT
SOUNDS LIKE.
>> Jesse: THAT IS THE '80s,
JUAN.
>> Juan: WE ARE VERY AMERICAN
FAMILY, WE ARE A COMMUNITY OF
PEOPLE.
I DON'T THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
INTENTIONALLY OFFENDING PEOPLE,
OH, I HAD SOME FUN.
I REALLY GAVE IT TO JESSE.
THAT IS JUVENILE.
>> Dagen: THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE
BRINGING TO THE TABLE, YOU THINK
SOMEBODY WEARING A MAGA HAT IS
DOING IT TO OFFEND YOU.
THAT IS A STEAMING PILE OF HORSE
WHO WE, AND YOU KNOW IT, JUAN.
>> Jesse: NOW THAT PEOPLE KNOW
THAT IT UPSETS PEOPLE WHEN THEY
SEE A RED HAD TO, LIKE YOU SAID
ABOUT THE HAMBURGERS, THEY ARE
JUST GOING TO WEAR IT MORE.
>> Brian: WHOOPI GOLDBERG WAS
A BREAKING POINT, PEOPLE HAVE TO
RESPECT PEOPLE.
MY HOPE IS THAT JUST BECAUSE WE